- It's amazing to see
everybody come together
each October to support
breast cancer awareness.
But there's one athlete who went way past
just wearing pink.
Look at this post about
former running back
DeAngelo Williams.
In honor of his mom and several aunts
who died from breast cancer,
he paid for mammograms for 500 women,
and he doesn't plan on stopping, y'all.
(applause)
We've got DeAngelo on Skype right now!
What's up DeAngelo?
(cheering)
Hi, I'm Kelly!
Okay, so first of all,
you are a great man.
Like, just a great example of a man.
Thank you so much first of all for that.
(applause)
And tell us a bit about your foundation.
- So, my foundation started in 2006.
That's when obviously I got
drafted and stuff like that.
My four aunts and mom all
carried the BRCA1 gene,
and after 2006,
I'd already lost three aunts
to the breast cancer.
And then in 2014 I lost my mom
and my other aunt before that.
So I lost my four aunts
and my mom to it, so--
- That is just devastating.
- Because I lost them to that disease,
I started this because I
didn't want anybody else
to feel the way that I felt.
So in 2014, we started
the 53 Strong for my mom.
She was 53 years old and
we give those mammograms
and that's how we ultimately hit 500.
- Oh my gosh.
(cheers and applause)
So how do you feel about finally reaching
the 500 mammograms?
How's that make you feel?
That's a big goal!
- Well, it is.
I feel pretty good, but I'm not there yet,
where I wanna be in terms of,
you know I wanna save every
life that I possibly can.
But at the same time, I
don't know if you know this,
but there's no camera when
we do stuff like this,
'cause I don't do this for
clicks, likes, or follows.
I do this to save lives, (applause)
'cause I don't want anybody to experience
what I've experienced.
(cheering)
- You're a very good man.
What's next for you and the foundation?
- Well, this is my ultimate goal.
We've given mammograms
in four different states.
We wanna do it all 50
states simultaneously,
and go overseas and do it as well.
I wanna leave this world better
than what it was when I found it.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- That's the reason why I
do the things that I do,
and on top of that, there's no formality
in terms of how much mammograms cost.
Like a mammogram in North Carolina
could be twice as much as a
mammogram in Pennsylvania.
So there's no set price for a mammogram,
so that's my ultimate
goal is to give fifty
"53 Strong for Sandra" mammograms,
all 50 states, and in the world.
(applause)
- Well, I'm gonna support this
as much as I possibly can.
I thank you so much for all that you do.
I'm so sorry you went through all
the devastating loss in your life,
but what you're doing with that loss
in turning it around and
trying to be positive
is an amazing thing so thank you so much.